[Music]
so I'm definitely I'm a professor of
neuroscience in tel-aviv University in
Israel and in the past ten years or so
I've been working on the relation
between sex brain and gender is there
such thing as a male or female brain no
there is no so as though there are sex
differences in the brain brain structure
and function and also we have lots of
evidence from animals that sex sex
chromosome sex hormones do affect brain
structure and function
these effects do not adapt consistently
with it within individual brains to
create two types of brains instead they
mix up in each of our brains so each one
of us has a unique mosaic of features
some are more common in males other are
more common in females but these mosaic
brains they do not sort into two types
what were examples they then are the
difference of characteristics of like
masculine or feminine I think it's
easier to understand if you look at the
human behaviors or psychological
characteristics because it's the same so
you can discuss or or describe feminine
and masculine characteristics like for
impact for example being empathic it's
more feminine being aggressive it's more
masculine but when you look at some of
these for acoustics together in a single
individual it's rarely that someone has
only feminine or only masculine
characteristics most of us has both some
feminine characteristics and some
masculine and each is a unique mosaic so
I'm sure you know this about yourself
but how would you go about researching
this like how do you isolate empathy in
a brain right so in the brain we don't
look for these types of functions
because you cannot do this one to man I
want when mapping but what we do is look
at brain structure using imaging MRI for
example and then we can measure volume
of specific regions or we can measure
the strengths of connections between
different regions and what we do is we
look for the regions or features that
show the largest differences between men
and women in the specific sample that we
look at and then we look at each in the
to see whether these differences add up
in the individual brain so for example
if a specific region is larger on
average in women than in men then being
loud is a feminine type if you want and
being small is a masculine type and then
you can look at the natural region and
do the same but what you see is that
each brain has some features in the
female typical phone and other features
in the male typical form so this is what
we do what happened so if you average
out across all individual brains there
anything that points between male or
female or you can't characterize them in
any way this that's a reverse prediction
so if you if I know everything about you
let's let's put the brain aside for min
because it's easier with behaviors but
it's the same principle so if I know
what you like to do and what your
preferences and attitude etc I can
predict with high probability whether
you are male or female but usually this
is not the type of prediction I want to
make because I just look at you and I
know that your favorite I don't need you
know to give you 10 questionnaires or to
scan your brain to know whether you're
male or female usually I know that you
are male or female and I want to predict
your brain mosaic or your personality
mosaic so I want to predict if you are
you know would be interesting for me to
talk to you or not and I cannot do this
on the basis of your sex because the
only way the only thing I know is that
probably because you are female you
would have more feminine characteristics
than masculine characteristics but I
wouldn't know how many of each and more
important I wouldn't know what are your
feminine characteristic and what are
your masculine characteristics so if we
think for example a on two men one is
highly aggressive and likes to watch
porn and the other one is great in
navigation and is very good in special
material rotation that I know which men
I want to date right so both of them
have two masculine characteristics but
the question is not how many but which
one they have and what about the role
that culture plays in this could that be
so strong that it comes to shape having
a male or female brain right so you're
moving now to do another question which
is which is a question of nature versus
nurture
so we see differences
in brain and behavior and you ask where
these differences come from and this is
completely different questions so that's
before I answer this what we do is we
look at the differences we don't know
the sauce we don't care about the sauce
we only ask do they add up consistently
maybe the nature put them there maybe
nurture put them there we don't care
what we see that they never add up
consistently now the question of nature
or nurture you cannot really answer in
humans because there is no way to cancel
out culture so unless we live in a
gender free world which we don't we have
no idea whether sex contributes to the
differences we see between men and women
but I personally think it's not really
important because even today when we
have both sexes affecting us and gender
as a cultural system affecting us even
now we don't sort out so that nicely
into the main pipe and the women type so
it doesn't really matter I guess that
when gender does not there's no longer
exist we just be more variable than we
already are
so what does this change then what are
the ramifications of being able to see
individuals as having mosaic brains I
think we should as a as a culture or a
society we should strive that we can all
be able to see humans as the mosaic they
are instead of forcing us into these two
categories the male category in the
female category I think these categories
are highly restrictive to all both men
and women I think we all suffer from
this binary view of gender and of sex
and I hope we can get rid of this system
and just treat people as humans Andy are
you optimistic about that that we'll
ever be able to just see people as
humans and not as within sexes
it's I am always optimistic but I think
we could because for example our
attitude to color the skin color has
changed it's still need you know there's
a way to go but it has changed I think
if you ask people 200 years ago if they
would see white people in black people
as similar equal etc they would be
horrified by this idea and now we will
be
horrified by you know having separate
toilets for black and white people so I
hope we'll get there also with sex so
how the form of our genitalia would be
just one other features physiological
feature like the color of our eyes or
whether we use our right or left hand
and it will carry no further social
meaning and what you see is such
research all the findings of your
research as being feminist would you
describe yourself as a feminist
neuroscientist I'm in neuroscience and
the feminist does this affect my science
yes because our opinions affect our
science but especially it makes me more
aware of my preconceptions and I think
the problem with many scientists is that
they are not aware of their
preconceptions and one important
preconception is that of the binary view
of sex and this is a cultural thing and
it strongly affects our ability to think
out of outside of this binary and in
this way it restricts our ability to do
good science when it comes to sex and
the brain or sex in general so I think
being a feminist any neuroscientist
helps me do better science and less
biased science because I'm more aware of
the structural and conceptualization
that structure my work or structure by
thinking so if this proof than the
gender is non-binary gender as a system
as a cultural system is binary but if we
if you think of gender of something that
you have then although most people do
have male or female genitalia
they don't have male or female nature so
they don't have a man or a woman gender
rather most of us have a mosaic of
different gender characteristics so in
this sense gender does not exist at the
individual level but it truly does at
the social level and has a strong impact
on each of us and so what areas research
does this then impact on that maybe now
can be explored further or even the you
guys do you decide to be done by other
people so getting rid of the binary view
of fair sex and gender is important even
for medicine for example
we need to study both males and females
but we need to be aware of not thinking
that there is male physiology and female
physiology because most of the features
that affect our human health and human
disease are not strictly or distinctly a
spread or divided into two sets so for
example sex hormones both males and
females have them there are dynamics
that are changing there are other
features that are related to sex they
don't split up nicely into two types so
the challenge is how we start studying
sex and sex effects on the body on the
human body
beyond this binary division and this is
a big challenge in science and I'm
trying to promote this and does this
mean that we should look towards
focusing on the individual yes so just
to give you an example in cardiovascular
diseases there are differences sometimes
between when men and women and there are
sought to be sex differences but it
turns out that some of these please some
of these differences relate or relevant
to height so there are actually height
differences taller people have different
flexibility of the arteries compared to
shorter people and because height is a
big difference between men and women it
was erroneously thought as a sex
difference but if you are a tall woman
then you should get a different
treatment than a short man or for a
short when a woman so this is an example
how the binary of sex really interferes
with us finding the mechanisms of health
and disease in developing new treatments
one final question where arts and ideas
festival other any other scientists
whose work has really inspired you that
you would like to recommend that other
people read or find out about yes so
unfair sister Ling has brought several
great books about sex and brain and
gender in this binary conventions and
Cordelia fine also had written several
great books the latest one is
testosterone Rex and I really recommend
a
a person to to read this and I'm
personally written now just going to
publish a book about all my ideas about
sex brain and gender and I hope you can
make a change and if you have to sort of
dilute that into a few sentences how
would you put that across your findings
from like the mosaic brain that most
humans can be divided into two according
to the form of the genitalia but this
division doesn't go beyond its interior
beyond the genitalia each human is a
unique mosaic of features some are more
common in females other are more common
in males but whatever you like and do if
it's appropriate to humans it's
appropriate to you for more debates
talks and interviews subscribe today to
the Institute of Arts and ideas at AI TV
you